hi guys i'm anirban from simply learn
and today i will be giving you a
tutorial on one of the most
talked about topics in the world of
technology and that
is machine learning i'm sure that if you
are watching this video
you must have heard about machine
learning somewhere or the other and yes
it is quite an intriguing topic this
video
will act as a supplement for the ones
who know the basics of machine learning
and are aware of where it is being used
and how it is being used
for the ones who are completely new to
this you don't have to worry
we will be brushing up the basics as
well so to start off with
let's have a look at the agenda first
we'll look into our life without machine
learning
then we'll move into a life with machine
learning
then we'll try to understand what is
machine learning actually
then we'll look into the types of
machine learning we'll talk about the
right machine learning solutions
then we'll move into the different
algorithms that machine learning has
let's talk about a life without machine
learning
for someone who doesn't know anything
about machine learning or artificial
intelligence
he or she might think that it is only
being used in robots or machines and
stuff
which is actually true as ported by most
of the sci-fi movies nowadays
but you wouldn't believe how much more
machine learning is giving us
how much of it we are using in our daily
lives
let's say you need information on any
random topic say
a computer the first place you would
check would definitely be google right
it would collect all the information on
the word you search for and present it
to you according to relevance
if there was no google you would have to
do it in a very hard way that is by
going to tens or hundreds of books and
articles
even after which you won't find the
answer
if we go back four to five years facial
recognition would be a thing
only showed in movies like mission
impossible or terminator or any of the
sci-fi movies you pick
but machine learning has made it
possible for facebook and instagram
to use this feature for your benefits
you don't have to go through the trouble
of tagging every single person present
in a picture that you have posted
facebook will automatically recognize
the people in the photo
and tag them for you that saves a lot of
time for you doesn't it
also siri cortana iris
all of them would not be there to help
you if there was no machine learning
now that we know life would be a lot
more difficult without machine learning
let's look into the things that are run
by machine learning and we are using
them on our daily basis
let's enter the world of gaming ps4s and
xboxes
have introduced virtual reality glasses
which brings a whole new level of detail
into gaming
every time your head moves in real world
it replicates the movement in the
virtual world providing an
excellent gaming experience then
there is gesture control gaming where in
machine learning tracks your body
movement and makes a corresponding
movement in the game
finally in the game fifa your opponent
tends to adapt based on the kind of
strategy or gameplay you follow
that is again done by machine learning
i'm sure you must have shopped a lot
from amazon so let's look into some of
the places amazon makes use of machine
learning
let's say you buy a formal t-shirt on
amazon
now as you buy it it suggests you formal
shoes
ties blazers and apparels that go with
what you have bought
that's the recommendation system powered
by machine learning again
the price on every product that you see
on amazon is varying every moment
based on demand that's being done by
machine learning algorithms
then comes customer segmentation
customer segmentation is one of the most
crucial thing
for all the e-commerce platforms machine
learning
helps them differentiate between
customers based on what they buy
how frequent are they and their reviews
this helps the companies to make sure
that their customers are taken care of
and the needs are being fulfilled
now let's talk about an app that you use
on a daily
basis to reach office on time yes it's
uber caps
once you have traveled with uber you
must have noticed that it suggests you
the places you might want to go based on
your previous journeys
when you are taking a share how does the
app make sure that the cab you get is
traveled by the same route
you want to travel in there are so many
factors like the distance the traffic
the ratings
all of it is taken care of by machine
learning
for the past five minutes we have been
talking about how machine learning is
improving our lives
where all it is being used i have
probably said machine learning 100 times
already
i think it's about time that i tell you
what machine learning actually is
let's take an ordinary system that you
currently are using
it can't do much except from the basic
operations that you already know about
now let's add artificial intelligence or
for a layman's point of view
let's give the same machine the power to
think on its own
that is what machine learning basically
is it's an application of artificial
intelligence that provides systems
the ability to learn on their own and
improve from experience without being
programmed externally so if your
computer had machine learning
may be able to play the difficult parts
of a game for you or probably solve a
complicated mathematical equation for
you
that could be really helpful let's dive
in a little deeper
and see how machine learning works let's
say you provide a system with the input
data that carries the photos of various
kinds of fruits
now you want the system to figure out
what are the different fruits and group
them accordingly
so what the system does it analyzes the
input data
then it tries to find patterns patterns
like shapes
size and color based on these patterns
the system will try to predict the
different types of fruit and segregate
them
finally it keeps track of all such
decisions it took
in the process to make sure it's
learning the next time you ask the same
system to predict
and segregate the different types of
fruits it won't have to go through the
entire process again
that's how machine learning works now
let's look into the
types of machine learning machine
learning is primarily of three types
first one is supervised machine learning
as the name suggests
you have to supervise your machine
learning while you train it to work on
its own
it requires labeled training data next
up
is unsupervised learning wherein there
will be training data but it won't be
labeled finally there's reinforcement
learning wherein the system learns on
its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised learning works
look at the pictures very very carefully
the monitor depicts the model or the
system
that we are going to train this is how
the training is done
we provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know
that these pictures were that of a fruit
called apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do is we provide a new set of data
which only contains pictures of apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you
what fruit it is and it will remember
this and apply this knowledge in future
as well
that's how supervised learning works you
are training the model
to do a certain kind of an operation on
its own this kind of a model is
generally used into filtering spam mails
from your email accounts as well
yes surprise aren't you so let's move on
to unsupervised learning now
let's say we have a data set which is
cluttered in this case
we have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data
to the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end
it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work
simple isn't it this kind of a model is
used by flipkart
to figure out the products that are well
suited for you
honestly speaking this is my favorite
type of machine learning out of all the
three
and this type has been widely shown in
most of the sci-fi movies lately
let's find out how it works imagine a
newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby
does not know that if it touches the
flame its fingers might get burned
so it does that anyway and gets hurt the
next time
you put that candle in front of the baby
it will remember what happened the last
time and
would not repeat what it did that's
exactly how reinforcement learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to
identify a particular kind of a fruit in
this case an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango
but as we all know it's a completely
wrong answer so as a feedback we tell
the system
that it's wrong it's not a mango it's an
apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us
the right answer it is able to tell us
that it's actually an apple
that is a reinforced response so that's
how reinforcement learning works
it learns from its mistakes and
experiences this model
is used in games like prince of persia
or assassin's creed or fifa
wherein the level of difficulty
increases as you get better with the
games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning
firstly the data involved in case of
supervised learning is labeled
as we mentioned in the examples
previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data
because its work is to look for patterns
in the input data
and organize it the next point
is that you get a feedback in case of
supervised learning
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point
is that supervised learning is mostly
used to predict data
whereas unsupervised learning is used to
find out hidden patterns or structures
in data
i think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
now let's talk about a question that
everyone needs to answer before building
a machine learning model
what kind of a machine learning solution
should we use
yes you should be very careful with
selecting the right kind of solution for
your model
because if you don't you might end up
losing a lot of time
energy and processing cost i won't be
naming the actual solutions because you
guys aren't familiar with them yet
so we will be looking at it based on
supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning so let's look
into the factors that might help us
select the right kind of machine
learning solution
first factor is the problem statement
describes the kind of model you will be
building or
as the name suggests it tells you what
the problem is
for example let's say the problem is to
predict the future stock market prices
so for anyone who is new to machine
learning would have trouble figuring out
the right solution
but with time and practice you will
understand that for a problem statement
like this
solution based on supervised learning
would work the best for obvious reasons
then comes the size quality and nature
of the data
if the data is cluttered you go for
unsupervised
if the data is very large and
categorical we normally go for
supervised learning solutions
finally we choose the solution based on
their complexity
as for the problem statement wherein we
predict the stock market prices
it can also be solved by using
reinforcement learning
but that would be very very difficult
and time consuming unlike supervised
learning
algorithms are not types of machine
learning in the most simplest language
they are methods of solving a particular
problem
so the first kind of method is
classification
which falls under supervised learning
classification
is used when the output you are looking
for is a yes or no
or in the form a or b or true or false
like if a shopkeeper wants to predict if
a particular customer
will come back to his shop or not he
will use a classification algorithm
the algorithms that fall under
classification are
decision tree knife base random forest
logistic regression and knn the next
kind
is regression this kind of a method is
used
when the predicted data is numerical in
nature
like if the shopkeeper wants to predict
the price of a product based on its
demand
it would go for regression the last
method is clustering
clustering is a kind of unsupervised
learning again it is used
when the data needs to be organized most
of the recommendation system used by
flipkart
amazon etc make use of clustering
another major application of it is in
search engines
the search engines study your old search
history to figure out
your preferences and provide you the
best search results
one of the algorithms that fall under
clustering is
k-means now that we know the various
algorithms
let's look into four key algorithms that
are used widely
we will understand them with very simple
examples
the four algorithms that we will try to
understand
are k nearest neighbor linear regression
decision tree and naive bayes
let's start with our first machine
learning solution k nearest neighbor
k near its neighbor is again a kind of a
classification algorithm
as you can see on the screen the similar
data points form clusters
the blue one the red one
and the green one there are three
different clusters
now if we get a new and unknown data
point it is classified
based on the cluster closest to it or
the most similar to it
k in k n is the number of nearest
neighboring data points we wish to
compare the unknown data with
let's make it clear with an example
let's say we have three clusters in a
cost to durability graph
first cluster is of footballs
the second one is of tennis balls
and the third one is of basketballs
from the graph we can say that the cost
of
footballs is high and the durability is
less the cost of
tennis balls is very less but the
durability is high
and the cost of basketballs is as high
as the durability
now let's say we have an unknown data
point we have a black spot
which can be one kind of the balls but
we don't know what kind it is
so what we'll do we'll try to classify
this using knn
so if we take k is equal to 5 we draw a
circle
keeping the unknown data point in the
center and we make sure that we have
five
balls inside that circle in this case we
have a football
a basketball and three tennis balls now
since we have the highest number of
tennis balls inside the circle
the classified ball would be a tennis
ball
so that's how k nearest neighbor
classification is done
linear regression is again a type of
supervised learning algorithm
this algorithm is used to establish
linear relationship between variables
one of which would be dependent and the
other one would be independent
like if we want to predict the weight of
a person based on his height
weight would be the dependent variable
and height would be independent
let's have a look at it through an
example
let's say we have a graph here showing a
relationship between height
and weight of a person let's put the
y-axis as h
and the x-axis as weight
so the green dots are the various data
points
these green dots are the data points and
d
is the mean squared error that is the
perpendicular distances
from the line to the data points are the
error values
this error tells us how much the
predicted values vary from the original
value
let's ignore this blue line for a while
so let's say if this is our regression
line
you can see the distance from all the
data points from this line
is very high so if we take
this line as a regression line the error
in the prediction
will be too high so
in this case the model will not be able
to give us a good prediction
let's say we draw another regression
line like this
even in this case you can see that the
perpendicular distance of the data
points from the line
is very high so the error value will
still come as high as the last one
so this model will also not be able to
give us a good prediction
so what to do so finally we draw a line
which is this blue line so here we can
see that the distance
of the data points from the line is very
less
relative to the other two lines we drew
so the value of d for this line will be
very less
so in this case if we take any value on
the x-axis the corresponding value on
the y-axis will be our prediction
and given the fact that the d is very
low our prediction should be good also
this is how regression works we draw a
line a regression line that is in such a
way
that the value of d is the least
eventually giving us good predictions
this algorithm that is decision tree is
a kind of an algorithm you can very
strongly
relate to it uses a kind of a branching
method
to realize the problem and make
decisions based on the conditions
let's take this graph as an example
imagine yourself sitting at home getting
bored
you feel like going for a swim what you
do is you check if it's sunny outside so
that's your first condition
if the answer to that condition is yes
you go for a swim
if it's not sunny the next question you
would ask yourself is if it's
raining outside so that's condition
number two if it's actually raining
you cancel the plan and stay indoors if
it's not raining
then you would probably go outside and
have a walk
so that's the final node that's how
decision tree algorithm works
you probably use this every day it
realizes a problem
and then takes the decisions based on
the answers to every conditions
nybis algorithm is mostly used in cases
where a prediction needs to be done on a
very large dataset
it makes use of conditional probability
conditional probability is the
probability of an event say
a happening given that another event b
has already happened
this algorithm is most commonly used in
filtering spam mails in your email
account
let's say you receive a mail the model
goes through your old spam mail records
then it uses space theorem to predict if
the present mail
is a spam mail or not so p
c of a is the probability of event c
occurring when a has already occurred p
a of c is the probability of event a
occurring when c
has already occurred and b c is the
probability of event c
occurring and p a is a probability of
event a occurring
let's try to understand knife base with
a better example
nybase can be used to determine on which
days to play cricket
based on the probabilities of a day
being rainy windy or sunny
the model tells us if a match is
possible
if we consider all the weather
conditions to be event a for us
and the probability of a match being
possible even c
so the model applies the probabilities
of event a and c
into the base theorem and predicts if a
game of cricket is possible on a
particular day or not
in this case if the probability of c of
a is more than 0.5 we can be able to
play a game of cricket
if it's less than 0.5 we won't be able
to do that
that's how knife-based algorithm works
so that
brings us to the end of the video i hope
you guys understood the concepts
put your doubts and feedbacks in the
comments below and stay tuned for more
videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here